few days ago
i saw in my twitter timeline
the most disturbing news story i think i
have ever seen and this came to me by
way of my friend lila rose lila rose the
founder of live action it was a series
of photographs of babies
obviously
babies no question whatsoever full-term
babies
who had been killed and they had been
killed apparently through abortion and
there was a whistleblower i guess at
this abortion clinic
and you could see the photos with your
own eyes
and the the police became involved and
there was an investigation and
the craziest part was the crazy beyond
obviously the
actions themselves the craziest part was
the police were investigating
the whistleblower they were not
investigating the people who killed the
babies that we could see with our own
eyes they were investigating
and and persecuting frankly the people
who would ever suggest that maybe
there's something wrong with this
joining me to discuss
is my friend lila rose lila thank you
for being here
good to see you michael so i
really don't know anything about this
story here's what i know i know that
five babies were photographed as having
been killed i know this took place in
washington dc i know that the remains of
the babies were found at a pro-life
activists home and i know the dc police
are letting the abortionists off the
hook and going after the pro-lifer
what
happened so to begin with as you
mentioned there are the remains of five
children so these are five babies who
some of them were nearly full term all
of them appear to be viable
when you look at the documentation and
live action was invited to do
photographic and video documentation of
these of the remains of these five
precious children you know almost a
dozen medical experts have been
consulted and have said that they
believe that at least two of these
children may have been born alive uh
viable babies before and alive and then
left to die or killed that one little
baby girl in particular about 28 weeks
old who has severe trauma to her body
her neck was cut her brain suctioned out
that appears to be an illegal partial
birth abortion a violation of federal
law so we're talking about two federal
laws that may have been violated here
just by looking at the remains of these
children and also dc statute against
illegal abortions the two federal laws
in question are the ban on partial birth
abortion the partial birth abortion ban
act and then the law called the born
alive infants protection act which which
ensures that a child if they are born
alive in an abortion clinic which can
happen in a late-term abortion procedure
that that baby gets the medical
care and the life that they deserve so
the bodies are right now the remains are
in the custody of the d.c police and the
medical examiner's office they initially
said well this is no illegal abortion
there was a press conference last week
but then the next day washington post is
reporting that the medical examiner and
the d.c police have said that there has
been no autopsy no thorough medical exam
examination has been performed so
they're claiming that there's no nothing
illegal here without even
autopsying the victim's bodies and then
meanwhile the pro-life activist at the
heart of the story
in particular lauren handy and other
activists from uh another group uh
they're the ones that came into
possession of this box of these aborted
children's remains that was given to
them by a whistleblower according to
them they they were the ones who worked
with dc police to hand over these bodies
so there's this news narrative right now
if anyone has been following the story
by mainstream press that the police
raided the pro-lifers apartment and
these crazy pro-lifers it is absolutely
dishonest it's a complete and utter lie
the pro-life activists are doing a
public service by intercepting the
remains of these children who are likely
illegally killed they they wanted to
give them a proper burial they wanted
justice to be served and a whistleblower
was involved and then they are working
with dc police inviting them to come to
their home to say look at these remains
and please have justice be served and
then instead of serving justice right
now dc mayor bower
dc police the dc medical examiner are
sitting on the evidence and no action
has been taken to investigate the real
uh criminal here i believe criminal
which is
cesare santangelo an abortionist
operating with impunity in the district
of columbia committing late term
abortions and infanticide on innocent
helpless children what was his name
again what was it
santangelo is the abortionist chaser
fantangelo
cesare santangelo and remember kermit
gosnell remember the butcher of
philadelphia the house of horrors this
abortionist that's thankfully behind
bars because he was also committing
infanticide i mean i think any
abortionist should be illegal a child in
or outside of the womb same value same
worth you don't get worth upon birth you
get worth the moment you become a human
being the moment you're you're you exist
as a as an embryo but cesare santangelo
is the butcher of dc he is the
kermit gosnell of washington dc remember
kermit gaza was operating for three
decades
um he even killed a woman medical
malpractice committing infanticide
authorities turned a blind eye until
finally they did their job after three
decades
that's what's happening here with cesare
santangelo and the reason it's happening
is because the dc mayor because the dc
police and because congress and our
president and his administration many of
them are pro-abortion and they don't
care about infanticide they don't care
about children's lives they care about
defending their political
ideology i am pro-life as you know you
are pro-life i was not always pro-life i
when i was a teenager even i get up to
maybe sometimes i forget exactly when i
was convinced of this maybe early 20 21
certainly though for my teenage years i
just i saw nothing wrong with it i
didn't think about it very much i grew
up in a very liberal liberal place in
new york then ended up going to a very
liberal college and it just didn't occur
to them i thought those pro-lifers are
crazy they just want to control women
i was convinced to be pro-life by a
bioethicist having a
ordinary conversation over a cup of
coffee
had i not been had i remained
pro-abortion
and then i saw these images
i don't think it would be possible to
continue to support legal abortion when
i saw the image i only made it through
two of them and i had to stop looking
when i saw the images i thought
do i retweet this it's a it's an
important story maybe the most important
story in the country right now that no
one wants to talk about or do i not
because it's so horrifying and i thought
i when i posted it i said if you are a
pro-lifer
and you do not support legal abortion
and you know where you stand and you
know the reality of this issue
don't look at it it's going to give you
nightmares don't look at it
if you in any way support legal abortion
and you're comfortable with that
position
look at every single one of these
pictures and tell me you you still
support that i think you would have to
be
a stone
cold sociopath to look at these photos
and continue to support abortion much
less like somebody and and write this
name down post this name on the roof on
billboards post this name on cesare
santangelo this
psycho this butcher this serial killer
this stone cold murderer who would do
this you would have to be
completely devoid of any human feeling
to do this or to to endorse it
i mean you're right michael you're
absolutely right and yes it is
devastating to look at the aftermath of
of a child that's been mangled that's
been tortured to death i mean two of the
babies were completely dismembered and
you know it's possible they were
dismembered dismembered while alive you
know typically the abortionist may try
to do a lethal injection first and then
dismember the child but sometimes they
just are sloppy and chaser is santangelo
we've been investigating him for a
decade he's sloppy he doesn't care he's
there to kill and he'll do it whatever
is the easiest means for him so living
dismemberment excruciating of an infant
this baby one of the baby girls that
looks like she was dismembered that was
dismembered um they were estimating
about 30 weeks old 30 weeks old that
that's who they're carrying
in for in neonatal intensive care units
across the country
and then in abortionists across the
country that same baby girl can be
dismembered while alive
yes it's it's devastating i mean i've
been a pro-life activist for
over 15 years now and i'm devastated i'm
broken all over again but listen if
we're pro-life
we should allow ourselves to be broken
by this and if we're not pro-life we
should become pro-life and it should
spur us to action because i agree with
you michael i think this is the biggest
story
in the country we can talk about a war
overseas we can talk about border crisis
we can talk about the economy we can
talk about all kinds of causes but how
we treat children is the definition of
who we are as a people and we are
treating them savagely and our laws are
permitting it in some cases our
authorities who should be intervening
and protecting these children are
permitting it
and we cannot allow this to continue so
you know one other note here live action
has been investigating cesaro santangelo
for a decade this abortionist told us on
undercover camera nine years ago this is
the first time he admitted it on
undercover camera that he would leave a
born alive infant in his facility to die
he admitted on tape already he would
commit infanticide and if you type in
his abortion clinic name anyone
listening if they're at their computer
they want to type in uh google search
google this sergi dc sergey center or dc
sergey health abortion the google
reviews for the business of this
abortionist two of them he has like two
two stars i mean no everybody who goes
there the women are just you know having
a horrific experience because he's
running a chop shop so that he's
murdering babies and you know
harming women but two of the google
reviews indicate that the women were
concerned their babies were born alive
going in for abortions
and they even say in the google review
that their baby might have been born
alive at 27 weeks um you know they
either she had to go to the hospital she
wasn't sure if they could resuscitate i
mean
it is it is a blatantly obvious story of
what's happening you could be the
dumbest police officer or mayor or
public official in the history of of any
civic system and get that this is a this
is a serious crime that's being
committed and we should do something
about it he's taking thousands of
dollars in exchange for dismembering
living infants
so how have we not done something about
this how have we not put this this
murderer behind bars even today i
believe he's at his clinic doing
continuing this atrocity so uh you know
i can't say strongly enough that we need
to take action we can't just sit in love
with a horrible story what horrible
pictures
we can uh change this by urging the
political powers to do the right thing
and by exposing these evils that are
taking place so you you point out that
the dc authorities are covering this up
and of course they're covering it up
they've been doing this for a long time
not just in dc but in lots of liberal
cities they're not ignorant they know
exactly people knew what was going on in
gosnell's chop shop people knew what's
going on in san tangelo's job shot and
and they're covering it up because they
support abortion it's it's become
frankly the sacrament of the left it's
not just safe legal and rare obviously
it's shout it from the rooftops uh
have have parades uh have
adulatory videos about how wonderful it
is to get abortions so they're they're
covering it up they're obviously
complicit
you say that this guy
almost certainly violated federal law
what about dc law
there are dc statutes against illegal
abortions there are dc statutes against
infanticide so this is not just you know
a hot potato issue oh the feds have to
take care of this i mean there are dc
laws that are being broken too i believe
so this is i mean every single
you know tom dick and harry in law
enforcement or every single um
politic political figure that has any
kind of responsibility should be alerted
to this they are alerted by the way they
already all know we've been
communicating with them and um you know
congress sent them a letter last night
uh 24 members of the senate and the
house and a letter to the mayor of dc
urging action so they know they know
and the big question is what will they
do because as far as we understand the
bodies are still the remains are still
in the possession of the dc police no
autopsy has been performed uh no
investigation is is being done into
chaser santangel that we know of right
now one other piece of information to
add to this sorted story is that the
medical waste company so the box of the
remains of the children was intercepted
from a medical waste company was given
by a medical waste company driver to the
pro-life activists and this company is
called curtis bay
and they're uh based out of maryland and
you know on their website as of last
week they said that they pride
themselves in doing cradle to grave
recovery of biomedical ways that they
then turn into renewable energy
that they would presumably power local
businesses and neighborhoods with in the
dc area so they're taking
they're taking the remains they were
taking the remains of children
and incinerating them to turn them into
renewable energy to then turn around and
sell it and you know it's it's beyond um
this is something you would read in a
dystopian horror novel but this is
what's happening and curtis bay of
course has publicly said oh these are
not our bodies we don't do this and they
actually took cradle to grave off their
website
we know whose bodies these are they're
the they're the kills of cesare
santangelo who's continuing to operate
with impunity in dc it's also the the
line cradle to grave is not true because
in a
even remotely anywhere close to just
society when someone dies at any age
they're put in a grave
here in this dystopia that we're living
in they're turned into energy to power
our blenders to power our our electric
lights that
sorry yeah i mean and that was another
thing that i thought was so um dishonest
about media coverage of the story is
there were some attacks even from some
uh self-posses self-professed uh
pro-lifers or even some i think uh you
know kind of the more um
they they claim to have religious titles
like christians or catholics um folks
that were saying well how dare the
pro-life activists have the remains of
these children and the reality is the
the pro-life activists who were given
these remains want to give them a proper
burial they want justice for them so the
people that are are truly treating these
children with dignity are the ones that
are exposing the horror with which they
were treated so that it stops and future
children are not treated that way and
that are trying to give these children a
proper burial because after being
unceremoniously murdered dismembered
treated
torturously uh to death not loved and
held like they deserved but killed they
were being sent to be burned and turned
into energy at some some some biomedical
incinerator i mean it is it is um
there's no better story today in this
country that reveals the depths
of america's horror story that is
abortion
and it's playing out in our nation's
capital and it is it is incumbent on all
of us to do something about it i love
america i do i'm an american patriot i
love my country i think it's good to
love your country you know my country
is is my country i could no more leave
my country or or deny my country than i
could deny my own family it's really
hard to love your country when you hear
a story like this it's really hard
you you're talking about and the the
the thing about this story
is that it's not unusual i guess that
that's the scariest part if it were
unusual if it were extraordinary that
would be one thing and you try to
prosecute this killer santangelo but the
the problem and probably the reason that
they're covering up for him is
this is a perfectly quotidian story this
happens all over the country every
single day and so if you go after this
guy if if the people in charge if the
ruling class admits that this guy is
doing what he's doing which is
slaughtering little babies then they've
got to go after all of the other ones
too the the the craziest part i guess is
that we're arguing over whether is this
a violation of federal law was the baby
killed five seconds after the baby came
out or five seconds before because
that's the decisive well what the hell
is decisive about that it's the same
baby it's five seconds
yeah you're exactly right michael i mean
our laws are schizophrenic but there are
still technically laws against
infanticide and shouldn't they matter i
mean apparently they don't not to not to
the dc mayor not to congress not to joe
biden in his administration right now
not to the department of justice the
current department of justice
but you know putting the story in
context you know there have been several
states in just the last month that have
tried to or are trying or have
legalized or further codified abortion
up until birth colorado's governor jared
polis just signed into law
a an act that will effectively legalize
abortion through all nine months any
reason no questions asked no conscience
protections for medical workers you know
they enshrined abortion as a right in
their law in colorado state law so if
you're a medical worker you don't want
to be participating in an abortion
you're not you know denying a woman her
right including for any late term
abortion um california there was a bill
in committee just yesterday that will
permit not just abortion through all
nine months in california which is
largely already permitted but also in
the perinatal period which can be up to
weeks after a child is born
and that would mean it decriminalizes
the killing the slaying the neglect
until death of a child even weeks after
he or she is born i've got to pause you
there so a member of our staff told me
this earlier to mention this to me i
hadn't seen the news story and i thought
oh you know look i i put nothing past
the radicals these days but
she just got that wrong there's there is
no way that's a little fantastical
you've been spending a little too much
time on the message boards you're
telling me this is real yeah the law
specifically states and anybody could
read it word for word live action news
is reporting on this right now go to
liveactionnews.org the law specifically
states that there will be no criminal
penalties that it's basically
decriminalizing any action
taken by a mother or and her doctor with
regard to her pregnancy including in the
perinatal period which is both the weeks
before birth and the weeks after birth
so if they decide to withhold care from
that infant according to this california
law if it goes into effect they cannot
be held criminally responsible i used to
make dark jokes lila i used to make sort
of dark when we talk about all the evils
of the country i said pretty soon the
left is going to be endorsing fourth
trimester abortion as something that
even for the radicals is just so beyond
imagination it could and and
it's it's now being seriously proposed
in california we've got to leave it
there we're out of time
your work on this story has been
incredible the work of lauren handy did
you say her name is the pro-life
activist is just absolutely incredible
where can people read more about this
and where can they find you
thank you liveaction.org is the website
i'm lila grace rose on twitter and
tweeting
reports on this all day long and there's
action items that people can take to to
make a difference here but i so
appreciate you covering it i know it's
hard i mean it's devastating but we we
can we can make a difference here in
saving the lives of children i think we
all should it's great work lila thank
you as always for coming on
[Music]
[Music]